this video was made possible by skill
share learn from over 25,000 classes for
free for two months at eskelta sh slash
went over six no sports league in the
world makes more money than the American
National Football League the NFL earns
more yearly revenue than the English
Premier League the Champions League
formula 1
the Japanese Nippon professional
baseball league and the Kontinental
Hockey League combined it is by far the
largest sports league in the world by
revenue making up the NFL are 32
football teams each themselves
essentially acting as their own distinct
businesses these teams are spread out
all across the contiguous United States
some only 30 miles or 45 kilometres
apart from each other some nearly 3,000
miles or 4,500 kilometers apart now
American football teams are some of the
largest in sports both physically and in
numbers they have a roster of 56 players
the majority of which play in any given
game these players away on average about
250 pounds or 110 kilograms this team
size leads to some particular travel
needs players each require a first-class
seat or at the very least the seat next
to them free an economy meaning those 56
players take up far more than 56 seats
on top of that a team typically brings
more than 100 support staff and an
immense amount of cargo to each away
game with the exception of the largest
most valuable ones most other
professional sports teams in the US will
just fly on chartered and narrow-body
aircraft like a320s 737s or 757s but
most NFL teams given their size require
something larger NFL teams tend to
charter their aircraft from commercial
airlines American Delta United or
Hawaiian Airlines and they'll typically
fly something a bit larger than other
teams like a 767 or sometimes even a
triple 7 but the nature of this charter
job makes finding a plane to take them
particularly difficult you see let's
take the example of the New York Jets
his last game of the 2018 season versus
the New England Patriots on December
30th for this game they left the day
before on a United Airlines 767 400 at
3:37 p.m. land
thirty minutes later at 4:07 p.m. in
Providence Rhode Island the plane then
sat on the ground at Providence Airport
for the next 26 hours until the game was
over the following day the plane took
off at 6:30 p.m.
bound for New York the aircraft's
previous flight had been to Buenos Aires
and its next flight was to London and
yet for these 26 hours United only made
money from the half-hour charter flight
to and from Providence it's easy to
understand why this wouldn't really be
worth it to the airline but at least the
Jets are located next to a United
Airlines hub and Newark Airport many
teams like the New Orleans Saints for
example are not located in a city with
any airline hub that makes finding an
airline to take their charter contract
even more difficult that's because for
example when the team had to travel to
Charlotte last season the 767 that took
them had to fly in empty from Houston
the nearest United hub then flight to
Charlotte sit on the ground for 33 hours
flight back to New Orleans than once
again flying empty this time all the way
to New York all tolled for those two
hours and 51 minutes of flight time
United was paid for they used this
airplane for almost 44 hours being
located away from an airline hub where
planes are based means charter flights
will almost always require a plane
flying in empty it is for this reason
that airlines are raising rates or just
flat-out stopping flying NFL teams as
they find normal commercial flying a
more lucrative use of their aircraft
American Airlines in recent years for
example dropped all the many teams they
previously flew except for the Carolina
Panthers the Dallas Cowboys and the
Philadelphia Eagles three teams located
at their hub airports more teams have
moved their contract to dedicated
charter companies such as Atlas air or
Miami air international while the New
England Patriots even bought their own
set of planes to solve this issue some
other teams still have contracts with
commercial airlines but have switched to
flying multiple smaller planes as these
can be in less demand the Indianapolis
Colts for example now typically travel
in two delta 757s leaving within a half
hour of each other other American sports
such as hockey baseball and basketball
don't have nearly as much of a problem
because they play far more games a
season which makes their contract amaura
one to Airlines and they also typically
use smaller aircraft of which there are
more available the NFL briefly
considered investing in its own fleet of
aircraft or at least negotiating a deal
with an airline in bulk like the NBA
does with Delta but for now NFL teams
are seeing their travel costs skyrocket
as the laws of supply and demand take
hold after losing their contract with
American Airlines for example the
Jacksonville Jaguars saw their travel
costs double to four million dollars a
year as they chartered an Atlas air 747
and remember those four million dollars
pay for the travel costs to a mere eight
away games but the NFL's most daunting
logistics problem is not this their most
daunting logistics problem relates to
the NFL's
other big problem expansion you see part
of the reason the NFL is the most
valuable sports league in the world is
because of how saturated the football
market is in the u.s. 57% of Americans
identify as NFL fans that's an amazing
level of market saturation for what is
at its core a business but that also
presents a problem because with such a
high proportion of the population arty
fans it's quite difficult for the NFL to
expand their audience at least within
the u.s. in the past decade or so the
league has turned its attention
internationally the NFL now plays
regular-season games in Mexico City and
London these cities don't have home
teams but rather two teams from the US
will come out and play
for the most part these international
games are about promoting the sport in
these two countries which already have
significant fan bases watching the sport
on TV there's never been more than one
game a season in Mexico City but in
London in the 2019 season they're
playing four regular season games with
the 16 regular season games per team per
year any other city that has a resident
NFL team typically only has eight home
games meaning London's quantity is
really not that far off
what's more the Jacksonville Jaguars are
designated as a sort of home team for
London and therefore play at least one
of their games there each year in an
attempt to give the city and country a
clear team to root for the league has
even said that it plans to eventually
have a full eight games per season in
London this
as any home city in the u.s. the reason
there are now so many NFL games in
London is because the sport of American
football has gained significant inroads
in the UK audience the NFL estimates
that it has 13 million fans in the UK
four million of which watch regularly
and 47 thousand of which buy games to
every single NFL game in the UK it's
dedication to the UK has become so
significant that it contributed 12.5
million dollars to the construction of
the new Tottenham Hotspur stadium in
North London this recently opened
stadium was built to become the home of
the NFL in the UK it has a permanent
synthetic American football pitch under
its Kraft soccer field purpose-built NFL
sized locker rooms and a media suite
built to the preferences of NFL press in
the coming years at least two NFL games
will occur each year at this Stadium now
the logistics of these international
games in London are formidable when the
Seahawks played in London in 2018 they
had to ship 1150 rolls of athletic tape
about 4,000 pounds or 1,800 kilograms of
medical supplies 350 power adapters 500
shoes 240 pairs of socks and tens of
thousands of other pounds of equipment
to the city weeks ahead of their arrival
months before they had to arrange for
many of their players who had never left
the US to get passports the team's
trainers had to carefully schedule their
player sleep in the week leading up to
reduce jet lag there's even a hotel in
Watford with a purpose-built American
football practice pitch that teams
typically stay in well.these London
matches come at great difficulty and
force teams to sacrifice a coveted home
game the teams and their owners seem to
tolerate them given their in frequency
and the promise of the UK market but the
promise of the UK market could push the
NFL to stretch beyond eight
international series games a year there
you see there is some very real very
serious discussion of putting a National
Football League team in London there is
little doubt that the city and country
could support a team in terms of fan
base the issue according to the league's
commissioner would be having one
solitary team stationed more than 3,000
miles or 5,000 kilometers away from the
next it would be an immense logistics
problem considering that for the weekly
games
teams would have to take flights as long
as 11 hours crossing up to eight time
zones on the flipside this London NFL
team would have to travel continuously
throughout the US for weeks at a time
since practically it wouldn't make sense
for them to return to London between the
weekly games this would come at enormous
expense would likely impact their
performance and proved unpopular with
their players in addition as the UK does
not yet have significant American
football talent the majority of this
teams players would come from the US and
would need to be persuaded either
monetarily or otherwise to live outside
their home country those are just some
of the cost problems beyond that it is
not cheap to fly a whole NFL team over
the Atlantic every week for the
International Series games teams were
flown on chartered Virgin Atlantic 747
or a330s
arranged by the league but if London had
a fully fledged NFL team it would likely
be treated just like any other team
meaning both them and their American
competitors would have to arrange their
own flights the wide-body planes teams
would have to charter to cross the
Atlantic come at a cost of up to $50,000
per flight hour that means that
transatlantic travel costs just in terms
of the flight would be anywhere between
six hundred and fifty thousand for an
East Coast team or up to a full 1
million dollars for West Coast teams
teams also tend to carry tens of
thousands of pounds of cargo to each
away game which would further escalate
the cost while such an expense would be
little issue for large wealthy teams
like the Dallas Cowboys or New England
Patriots teams with smaller budgets like
the Detroit Lions or Cleveland Browns
would certainly have more of an issue
with potentially adding an extra million
in travel costs but this level of team
isolation is not unprecedented further
west in the middle of the Pacific the
University of Hawaii has a Division one
college football team the Hawaiian
Rainbow Warriors the closest team in
their conference is 2600 miles or 4200
kilometers away in San Diego to get
there they take a five-hour flight
that's only an hour to faster than it
would take a London and FL team to get
to its closest competitor the New
England Patriots while the furthest team
in the Rainbow Warriors conference is
only a seven or eight hour flight away
in Colorado Springs Colorado they do
play a number of
non-conference games each year which
takes them all the way to the US East
Coast and up to ten hour flight away
from Honolulu which is almost exactly
the same as the longest required travel
time for an NFL team to London not only
that but the Hawaii Rainbow Warriors
also have to balance their time with
class schedules which means that they
travel to their away games far closer to
kick-off than NFL teams typically do to
London the Rainbow Warriors regularly
rack up more travel miles than any
professional football team for example
in one particularly grueling month in
2016 the team started this season with
an international match in Sydney
Australia then the next weekend played
in Ann Arbor Michigan than the weekend
after that played in Tucson Arizona
meaning they flew 25,000 miles or 40,000
kilometers in just one month the Rainbow
Warriors also make most of their trips
on commercial flight making their travel
even more difficult than that of NFL
teams now this does potentially give the
team a more significant home-field
advantage since they're used to playing
with jet lag while their opponents when
they fly to Hawaii would not be but it
also supports the view that logistically
it would be possible to add an NFL team
in London
there are even professional sports
leagues that already regularly require
travel over similar or greater distances
the Kontinental Hockey League for
example has teams spread out all across
Asia and Eastern Europe meaning the
teams from Vladivostok Khabarovsk and
Beijing regularly have to travel more
than 4,000 miles were 6,500 kilometers
to play the teams from Minsk Riga and
Helsinki an even more extreme example
would be Super Rugby which has teams
spread out across Japan Argentina South
Africa Australia and New Zealand with
this when the Tokyo Sun Mol's played the
Buenos Aires Jaguars for example they
have to travel more than 11,000 miles or
18,000 kilometers each way to their
match part of the NFL's problem is just
the pure scale of their competitions
with many tens of thousands of pounds of
equipment and many hundreds of staff
traveling to each game the problems are
sure mountable though at a cost with his
cost would be partially burdened by
every other team in the league
the question is then given the promise
of adding a whole new country to the
league is the cost worth it
now if the NFL expands to London one of
the first things the new team will need
is a logo luckily there's a class on
Skillshare for that professional
animator Frasier Davidson who actually
has done design work for the NFL teaches
this fantastic course which walks you
through the process of creating your own
mascot this is just one of over 25,000
classes on Skillshare which each teach
you something that you can use for your
job for school or just for fun a few
more that I would recommend are
storytelling 101 the productivity
masterclass and cinematography basics
all of which you can download offline on
the iOS and Android apps you can learn
from any of these more than 25,000
classes for free for two months by
signing up an SKS age / Wendover 6 and
you'll be supporting the show while
you're at it